[Music]
robert pattinson's performance in the
madman is a fascinating look at the
darkness that lurks inside the superhero
but there is one moment that exposes the
pain that bruce wayne suffers here is
the bruce wayne scene in the batman that
went too far fans of batman are well
aware that bruce wayne has a lot of
trauma to deal with especially when it
comes to his family as a young boy his
parents are both murdered leaving him an
orphan the tragic backstory is just a
part of what makes the characters so
rich and well-liked in matt reeves to
batman this aspect of bruce wayne is
still a crucial part of his story
because of what bruce goes through
growing up he desperately wants to stop
that from happening to anyone else and
to make gotham city a better place in
the new film fans get to see bruce
devoted to finding and stopping the
riddler and ridding the city of
corruption he works with james gordon
and selena kyle to get that job done in
the end bruce is a hero and it looks
like there is still some hope for gotham
to be better but even as a superhero
bruce certainly isn't perfect he's human
with issues that he has not fully dealt
with yet and this leads him to make some
bad decisions the batman highlights
these flaws alongside bruce's strengths
leading to one scene in the new film in
which bruce arguably takes a
conversation one step too far chances
are you already know that the man who
raises him after his parents deaths is
none other than his butler alfred
pennyworth alfred is a wonderful
parental figure and while bruce has some
things he definitely needs to work on he
turns out to be a pretty stand-up guy
but in the batman the riddler schemes
hit a little too close to home for bruce
causing him to question everything he
thinks he knows about his father thomas
wayne and in turn alfred in the first
half of the film bruce exhibits signs of
carelessness when it comes to his own
well-being sure he wears bulletproof
armor and can take care of himself in a
fight but he also takes unnecessary
risks and doesn't seem to care for much
outside of his vengeance with the new
mayoral candidate bella rael
highlighting the need for change on the
ground in gotham alfred brings up the
topic of the wayne legacy of
philanthropy to bruce alfred tells bruce
that the young man has no consideration
for maintaining the wayne family legacy
as upstanding citizens of gotham and
that's all bruce cares about as bringing
justice through batman he wants to
inflict his kind of justice
he's just compelled to do it he doesn't
even seem to give a second thought to
the idea of wayne's holdings and other
projects completely falling apart then
when alfred pushes once more bruce
responds emotionally snapping back at
alfred while bruce is likely pushing
alfred away to keep them both from
getting hurt he does more damage than he
thinks alfred's devotion and love for
the wayne family are probably the basis
of his identity and life audiences get a
deeper sense of this in the scene when
bruce is getting ready to attend the
mayor's funeral and alfred gives bruce
his wayne cufflinks to wear bruce
questions why alfred has them as he's
technically not a wane alfred reveals
that they were a cherished gift from
bruce's father bruce realizes that his
father giving alfred the cufflinks was a
declaration of alfred becoming a part of
the family bruce doesn't necessarily
apologize to alfred about the offense
and so many words but he realizes the
truth that alfred really is family after
the riddler's attempt on bruce's life
almost kills his devoted father figure
bruce stays by alfred's side in the
hospital as he recovers once he wakes up
the two have a very important
conversation about thomas and the things
bruce finds out about his father from
the riddler
look at this latest it's all about the
wings ultimately the scene builds to
them having a touching moment together
although bruce takes his anger and grief
a step too far in the earlier
conversation he thankfully comes to his
senses by the end of the batman and
makes it clear to alfred that they are
in fact family
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]